are you a job seeker looking to make the
most of the european job market
or are you an employer open to
recruiting from europe's vast talent
pool
then look no further than eures your
partner in recruitment for job seekers
and employers
throughout europe
frontiers
the eures job mobility portal provides
access to jobs
cvs events labor market and other
practical information
in 32 countries across europe whenever
you need it
the person who is looking for a job in
another eu country
has a place where to start he knows he
can start from eures
and the difference and the added value
of eures is the fact that behind
the website there is a whole network of
people who are working
for it more than 900 networked eures
advisors
specialists in job mobility provide
tailored information
guidance and placement services to
ensure your job move or recruitment
is safe and efficient
they can assist you with writing a good
cv and application letter
publishing and disseminating a job
vacancy and
finding the right match this is
the european jobs network can help
individuals grow through working abroad
and businesses benefit from talented
people wherever they are in europe
foreign
working abroad is a win-win experience
so make it happen log on to the eures
portal
to get informed find a job post your cv
find candidates for your vacancies or
participate in one of the on-site or
online job fairs
if you need more help contact a eures
advisor
via the portal or at your local public
employment service
different cultures working together
create a different way of working
which we experience to be an advantage
in many ways
when you are flexible you can find a new
job you can
working not only you before profession
you can find a new profession why not
eures a bridge between employers and job
seekers across
europe offering pan-european employment
solutions
you